women are better drivers though you have  to admit no no  they're not they they have less  accidents but it's only because men  drive more so actually like per yeah and  men actually drive more dangerously yes  i would say  yeah are better but the thing is but the  thing is women take less risks driving  so they're better no but it depends on  what you mean as better because no i  think they disapprove  sorry i think they disproved that really  were they like like that's what i  thought it was too  but i want to say they just disproved it  and they said that actually men are  better drivers  men have less accidents for how much  they drive right okay so then when you  were saying women are better drivers why  is it there on this is not a formula one  women's race because like why is there  nothing  women's thing  that's a different type of driving